she says, there was a mean trick with the vomitin,
all that.
I don't know, it kind of spells it new.
Yes, you do all the time.
Well, mine are always funnier.
They have an ironic sort of twist.
I cast Tasha's hideous laugh, too.
I think.
Make a saving throw if you'd be so kind
for Tasha's hideous laughter.
Oh.
Would you roll?
Four.
Do I have points to add to it?
Does she like, reverse it at her?
That she does.
Whoa!
That's badass.
I know, that's just a fucking badass.
I can't do the school laughing, you're like a crazy bitch.
This is just, oh no.
This is just so cool.
I love Shizuko.
Make a, what's your roll for your wisdom save?
Four plus wisdom.
Plus wisdom, four's not gonna do it.
Great.
You start cackling like a lunatic.
Ah!
No.
I also need to have you make a wisdom saving throw
for your panic attack condition.
20. 18 plus two.
18 plus two, cool.
So you don't go into a panic attack,
but you do start laughing like a lunatic.
You see, she says, see, for example,
I just said that my spells were funny,
and I've turned your laughter spell back on you,
with both ironic and funny,
which are the two things that I said my spells are like,
and I didn't even have to use a spell slot.
Isn't that something to learn so many spells
for you?
This is my only game going to this school
to find a group of people to destroy you in a fucking life.
You see, she says, I'm sure you will.
You're going to join one of those little arcane secret societies.
I punch her in the face.
Go ahead and make an attack roll.
Did you use up all your spells slots on your sister?
He just died in your opening.
Three. Three.
You went, your skinny, elven fist whiffs right past your face,
and she says, that's sort of pure, brute, physical violence.
I'm sure we'll earn you all sorts of credits
at this school for brawling, and it's lovely.
Well done.
You see, she says, can I, before you injure yourself
by trying to attack me, can I just be very clear
about something?
Look, she says, I,
it's awful that you got kicked out of Xutong.
It's awful.
It doesn't reflect well on our family,
but that's not even the reason.
I punch her in the face.
Good point again.
Eight.
She says, really stop.
What's the game at this point?
I'm throwing punches.
The game is me hitting you in the face.
She says, I'm trying to help.
No, you're trying to help yourself.
No, look, all right, I just, let me do,
I'm trying to do a nice older sister thing for once.
Can I do it? Can I do that?
Can you?
Good grief. All right.
Look, egg fort doesn't work like you, doll, all right?
So all the things about grades and tests and practicals
and exams and all that, that's all out.
It's a nonsense place.
It's all topsy-turvy there, all right?
They look differently on the sort of things
that they value there.
So the things that really, really work for that academy are sort of things that would
be insane to do at Xutong. I heard that one of the best ways to get into an arcane society
was to steal a book from the restricted section on your first day. That that's something that
they look at as, I don't know, some kind of adventurer's initiative or it shows, I don't
know, gumption, something along those lines. I don't want to take it any more advice from
you because you probably couldn't even get into egg fort just because you're good at
a huge old, doesn't mean you'd be good at egg fort.
I could do that. I could turn that whole school around brick by brick.
I'm lifting up in the air. You're too scared to try. You're too scared to try.
I am proper and well behaved and well mannered.
So I don't care to engage this anymore.
All right, fine. Go on your first day. Get partnered up with some sort of barbarian.
Go out into the wilds and get killed on your first adventure. See what I care.
Good. I shall. See she walks away.
Whoa.
10 choose.
Hell yeah.
We now go over to...
Going out to Ballister, which is kind of like, you know, more rundown, more seedy kind of place, kind of bad part of town.
We see a strong tower luxury apartments with the luxury kind of arcano crystals flickering.
So it just goes to strong tower apartments.
We see that there is a small bedroom and basically like, you know, like a kind of retrofitted,
like it's like a one bedroom apartment with like a kind of cordoned off, you know, like
bed in the living room with like a fake drywall around it. Very small apartment.
And we see that there's like, sun's just coming up. There's like, you know, some smoke coming from like,
you know, some burning thing on the other and there's a little bit of like coffee and a mug.
A very sparse Spartan kind of place. And we see Riz Guck Gack. Brian, go ahead and describe Riz for me.
Yeah, so I'm Riz Guck Gack. My nickname in middle school was briefcase kid. I'm a goblin. And I don't
have a lot of friends, even though I'm pretty social, which is weird. My only real friend was
his halfling named Penny Luckstone, who technically my babysitter, I had a babysitter until I was 13,
but she recently went missing.
And my mom is a detective and I'm a licensed private investigator.
So I am gonna find Penny myself.
So it's early in the morning.
I assume you've been up all night, working your case.
I've got my board that just has the missing girls
all just pointed at the school.
And that's all I have.
Ew, that's so creepy to have a little boys room.
I just have a board of missing girls.
He's trying to find them.
Whatever, Greep.
You're not here.
None of you are here.
You know you take breaks and kiss a pillow.
Penny, thank you.
So Riz is there not kissing a pillow?
Just being a private investigator.
You see that it's early in the morning.
You're kind of looking at the board.
It's a lot of, it's a really nice board.
You got with the yarn and everything.
It's kind of sparse clues-wise.
It's sort of just the pictures and the dates
where they went missing and stuff like that.
Trying to move it around to make it different,
but I only have five clues.
You see that the door opens and your mom, Sklonda,
got Gakwaks in.
Sklonda's a classic goblin.
She's got sort of like green skin, yellow eyes,
the big ears that come out to each side.
But it's got that classic mom haircut, you know what I mean?
Kind of like the bangs and the kind of bob or whatever.
She wants to get the sort of white shirt.
She's got an underarm holster for a little arcubus dress.
She wants to get like the badge hanging off the belt there.
You see that she opens the door, walks in.
She's been gone all night working.
You see that she walks in and she goes,
ah Riz, sweetie, are you up?
You're up? What are you doing?
I got some sleep.
I slept for four hours.
So he said four hours was the minimum.
Four hours was the minimum.
I got four hours of sleep.
Okay.
I got up a couple of times to work on the board,
but for the most part, four hours of sleep.
Sweetie, you know that it's not great that you're doing this, right?
Well, they're, you know, they're missing.
Why does this say licensed private investigator?
It says, well, it says, it's little, but it's legal.
Looks like a smudge. Oh, sweetie, that's...
Technically legal. Really skirting the line.
But overall okay.
Yeah, I look sweetheart, you got a lot of gumption, but we have detectives that are working. Actually,
we have one detective working this case, but... And I can be a man on the inside. And the inside.
Yeah. The egg at the school, right? That's where the girls all went to the school. Yes,
they all went to egg four. And that's the clue that I have. She looks at your one clue.
She looks at me for it. She says, okay, you could throw a couple more clues on there. There's
a couple of things we could, you know... Just read a newspaper. Yeah, we'll just read a newspaper.
The dates, right? You got circumstances. Last scene, last person scene. That's why it's
good to have you around, mom. Why am I encouraging this? Don't do this. Skriveling dates. Don't...
Oh, God. Okay. Are you hungry? Are you hungry? What's the need? I had coffee. That's not food,
sweetie. I haven't eaten. Okay, I'm gonna go and get some. What do we have? She opens the
fridge and it's empty and she says, okay, I gotta go shopping. You see that she opens the thing
and there's some cereal. She takes a little thing of cereal out, pours two bowls, pours some
milk in. You see that there's not enough milk for two bowls so that she pours the milk out
of her bowl into yours and puts water from the sink in it. And you see, she puts it in
front of you. And you see that she goes... Don't cry. Don't cry. Try your best. I love her.
You see, she says... Shout out, mom. All right. Well, heat up, okay? Okay, thank you.
All right, well, I'll find a time to go shopping and get the rest.
Hey, today, first day of school, right? Yeah.
And this Saturday, you know, it's the five-year anniversary.
So if you wanna head over to the cemetery, we can go visit dad
and sort of see how things are going. Yeah, we can do that.
Does that work for you? Yeah. We can go in the morning.
If you got stuff to do, because I know you probably try to make friends at school.
Yeah, I'm probably gonna be busy because I'm gonna make...
So I figured a lot of kids would just be giving out their phone numbers on their phone,
but I made business cards.
So I'll probably be busy Saturday. Why don't we do it in the morning?
Yeah. Formality is great when you're trying to be a professional.
And I know that you see me work a lot, and so that's kind of a professionalism.
But there's something to be said. When I go out with the guys, I'll knock back a beer.
I'll kick back a little bit. It's okay to relax.
Yeah, get them relaxed.
Do get them relaxed?
That's how we get them to tell us...
You relax.
...the secrets so that we can solve the mystery.
Friends are for more than clues, sweetie.
Friends are for...
There's a lot of things we use friends for, right?
So let's look at that as an opportunity to...
Start with the friends, then get the clues.
Okay.
You get to the bus.
I'm gonna try to...
All right, I'm gonna catch a little bit of sleep.
Sweetheart, you're gonna do great.
Thanks, Mom.
You're the best there is.
I love you.
Have a great day at school.
Tell Mom about when you get home, okay?
Okay, thanks, Mom.
It gives you a kiss on the head, and she heads off to her bedroom.
And we will now cut over to our final...
Nice.
Oh, hell yeah! We cut over to the Fayeth home, way over by the highway.
Not so many people live out here. It's kind of a little house, chain-link fence.
It's kind of a little attic bedroom up there.
Ooh, I live... I'm in the attic?
You're in the attic.
Fuck yeah.
Upstairs is a room that last year was filled with pastels and little unicorns and other shit like that.
And now it's all fucking banned posters, tour lists for who's gonna be playing the black pit.
There's a sick red guitar in the corner. There's some like horn cream.
There's like some cream for like kind of like your horns that are coming in.
See... Emily, go ahead and describe your character if you would.
My name's Figaroff. You probably know me last year. It's like that really bubbly girl who was like invited to every party.
But all of a sudden my horns started growing in and I thought I was an elf, but it turns out my dad isn't my real dad.
And I have a demon for a dad, but my mom won't tell me who he is. So pretty much I'm kind of like, fuck everyone.
And I'm just like, I'm just like, I've got a bass guitar.
I've got some drumsticks.
Like I'm ready to start a bass-driven band.
And just like, yeah, just fuck everything.
Right? Okay, that's it.
That's me. Also, my name is Figaroff.
My last name is Faith, but that is the name of someone
who does not have anything to do with me
because he's not my dad.
So I'm just Fig now. Just Fig.
You see that, so Fig is upstairs.
You see that there's a knock at the door. You're in bed.
See that your mom leans in. Your mom is, she's got like the mom jeans on, but it's like a sort of wood elf.
You see that she's got like a bow over her shoulder in a quiver of air.
Your mom wears this arranger that goes and explores the woods around here.
You see she goes, sweetheart, I've been knocking up a storm. What's going on? You're going to be late. You're going to miss the bus.
Oh yeah, about that, I'm not going.
God damn it, you're going to school.
Yeah, try and tell me even one good bard
who learned how to bard in school.
They're gonna teach me how to play the bass guitar?
No, if I want, I need real life experience.
The school is real life experience.
Sweetie, you're 15.
Who's my dad?
God damn it, I'm not.
I can't tell you who you're,
your dad is Galiir who raised you and loves you.
Okay. That tool.
Look, just cause things aren't great between your father
and I right now doesn't mean that he doesn't love you.
Okay?
Really? Because the look on his face
when my horn started growing in
didn't look a lot like love.
Sweetie, this attitude is a problem.
All right, you got to get it together.
It's your first day at school.
You know what you're right, I think I need some instruction,
like maybe from a dad.
God damn it, I.
Who is he?
Just give me a name, I'll go find him myself.
There are reasons I can't tell you.
Is he the Nightmare King?
It's not the Nightmare King.
It's the Nightmare King.
You don't have to say, say it's not the Nightmare King
if it's the Nightmare King.
Say it, you want me to say what?
If it's not the Nightmare King, you could let me know
by being like, it's not the Nightmare King.
The Nightmare King lives thousands of miles away from here, maybe.
Yeah. I did.
But he also lives in our nightmares.
Maybe that's where you met him.
Sweetie, this is sensitive in adults.
I light up a cigarette.
Where the fuck did you get a cigarette?
She snatches out of your hand.
I don't, where did you get that?
I light up another.
God!
Where did this come from?
You were so well-behaved a year ago.
See, she sort of like collapses against the wall.
Look, okay, well, and she looks out the window and goes,
well there goes the fucking bus, huh?
There it goes, are you happy?
Bye.
Anyway, so I think I'm just gonna sort of stay home
and work on some music.
I've got a song called My Dad is a Demon,
but he's also a deadbeat.
So, I'll just work on that.
You're going to the school.
Bye. And you see that she walks out,
picks up the phone, and she calls someone,
you can hear her speaking in elven downstairs, going,
I can't believe it.
I thought I was in the elf.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my God, just so many T.H. sounding.
I don't know if I'm a fig.
I know you're talking about me, I can hear you saying fig.
I've got nothing to do with you.
Get downstairs.
You see your mom comes back upstairs and goes,
I have to go to work, all right?
Your father is coming here to pick you up
and take you to school, all right?
Because- Oh my real father?
I'm finally gonna meet him.
What a luxury.
I can't wait.
I'll put on my best fucking dress.
Get dressed for school, all right?
And we will talk about this.
I love you, and I know this is hard right now,
but we're gonna get, you gotta put the cigarette out
while I'm in the room.
While I'm in the room, you can't smoke.
I put it out in her closet.
God damn it!
You see that she walks out of the room.
Just tell me who my real dad is
and I'll call this war off.
She walks out of the room, she leaves,
you see that she walks out on the front lawn
and a humongous griffin flies out in the sky.
I'm like, ah!
Lands in the front yard, she mounts on its back and flies off.
Oh, oh.
Okay, that's pretty dope.
You see that a moment later, a car rolls up
and Gilear, who you, not your biological father,
but the man who raised you, steps out of the car.
He's not looking great.
He's sort of lost some hair.
You've never seen an elf with a comb over before.
He's got like a little bit of a punch.
He's got like a little sort of short sleeve button up shirt.
He's like working at a different job now
because he quit his old one and he's got like some,
what do you call it, like beans or something on his shirt?
Oh, yeah.
You see, he steps out of the car and knocks on the door.
Tunk, tunk, tunk.
Hey, go answer it.
Gilear, have you been eating out of cans again?
What?
Oh, my daughter.
Yes, I have been eating out of cans.
I've been eating legumes, as it were,
for I have found that in my new living situation
over at Strong Tower luxury apartments.
Wow, you really emphasize luxury.
They're not the worst in the world. They're all right.
But I've found that, you know, I've been eating beans.
Eating beans.
Okay. So I'm guessing you were sent here to try and get me to go to school, right?
Well, I'm going to give you a ride.
Okay, let me just go use the bathroom and then I'll come.
Okay, that sounds good.
I go into the bathroom and I cast a sky self to make myself look like my mom.
And then I come back out.
You walk back out and you see he goes, Sandra Lynn, what the hell?
I thought you needed to go to work.
I know, I've changed my mind.
I don't think she should go to school.
She made some really compelling arguments about how Bards,
how Bards need real life experience.
So thank you so much.
And also thank you for keeping it a secret
who her real dad is.
Well, all right.
But between you and me, we can say the name out loud.
So you see, he says, well, he's actually, if you want to go talk to him about the paternity
test, we can, he's free today.
Yeah.
Yes, I do.
Can we do it in the next hour?
Sure, that's fine.
Okay, yes.
That's no problem.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
She's upstairs.
So we can just go.
No need to say goodbye to her.
Really?
No need to say goodbye to her?
No, I think she's working on a song.
Okay, that's right. I'll talk to her later. You see, he goes and gets in the driver's seat
of the car. Okay, I'm coming. You sit. What's the duration on your disguise self spell? One
hour.
Cool. Everyone else goes to school. That's my friend.
The sun rises in the sky over the beautiful dappled lawns, stone brick walls, ivy covered
trellises and statues of the Egg Fort Adventuring Academy. All of you arrive by bus, by car, however
you get here. Out in the front of the building, you see a bunch of students, people that recognize
each other, clapping and loud teenagers and everyone's kind of gathering. You see her a few
minutes early. You see that your father pulls up to the front of the school.
You got a trick. You see, he goes, all right, Sandra Lynn, here you are, your former lovers
in there. You think I'm a fool? I raised you and don't call me Gilear, all right? I know
that I said- What? What else am I supposed to call you, stranger? Stranger with no biological
link to me? I'm willing to make that a lot to say every time I address you. You see little
tear forms in his eye and you see he says, I know that I said some hurtful things when
I first found out. Yeah, you said you're no longer a faith and guess what, I'm not. I'm
just fig now. Fig, I'm sitting here with beans on my shirt. I know, I saw you ate one on the
ride here. I was hungry, all right. I put on some weight. You ever heard of a fat elf?
I never seen a fat elf in my life and I'm here with a bad come over beans on my shirt.
Okay, fine. I'm sorry, Gilear. I'm sorry that I got angry at you. You're just some random
man. I shouldn't be mean to you.
All right, get out of my fucking car, you demon. I didn't mean it like it's not- No, no,
no, no, because you're making it a tiefling thing.
You know what? I am a demon.
And then I put some hornwax to really make him shoddy.
And I'm not ashamed of it.
I just hope I don't also get a tail.
The horns are enough.
Okay, bye.
Brad, you guys all arrived at the front of the school.
What are you guys all doing here together?
Oh, I look around for the biggest and the strongest man
or student in the kind of the entry area.
You look around.
You see, what's Gorygug doing?
He's the tallest person here.
I'm holding a metal flower.
I was looking for a friend.
I walked straight up to Gorygug and I say, hey, how you doing, buddy?
I'm good. It's my first day. I guess it's everyone's first day.
Oh, it's your first day.
Do you want this metal flower?
I swear you're hitting the fucking wall.
I'm not gonna fucking care.
I see this just as I'm walking into the wall.
I'm like, this is what this school is.
Go ahead and roll an attack roll.
Great.
15.
What's your AC?
My AC is 13.
You slug him. What's your strength modifier?
It's two.
You take three points of damage.
And then I turn and I say, I'm Fabian's feet.
I'm Seacaster, son of Bill Seacaster.
And I'm here to be great.
I'm trying to sing that song.
I run up.
Are you okay?
What happened?
That guy punched me.
That sucks.
You seem really nonviolent.
I think that's really cool.
Violence is never the answer.
I go to a rage.
What?
Awesome. What are you?
I go to a rage and I attack.
I go to punch.
Go for it. Roll an attack roll.
Oh.
19.
What's your AC?
Oh, 16.
And you're in a rage, right?
Yes.
So that's gonna deal three plus two plus one
is six points of damage.
No.
You fucking...
Gorgug whips up and fucking clocks. Wait, no, violence isn't the answer. Is this creating
like a commotion? Are there people in the... Are the teachers all around? You see there's
this one kid who looks like a gnome with like that long kind of like stoner hair
who's like, oh fuck, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight. You can start going fucking crazy.
I'm gonna sneak into the teachers lounge while there's a commotion and steal from the refrigerator.
You sneak in. You guys see that way into the crowd of students is this hulking dragonborn.
For those who don't know, the dragonborn is humanoid dragons, long tail, no wings, these big claws,
wearing a full suit, like a gray suit and a blue tie, big horns sweeping off of like this,
he's like red scaled anthropomorphic dragon guy. You see he's holding just a straight up cricket bat
in his hands and he walks up and goes, all right, all right,
that's enough and on day one, the bell hasn't even rung yet.
Effortlessly hoists you two up off the ground,
sheathing his cricket bat before he does so and goes,
no, look here, what, what, what are you, freshman?
How, why did this even start?
Well, I don't know.
You hit me.
Well, I had to let this one know that I wasn't going to take any of the shit.
Shit, it looks like he's holding a phone.
He's holding a flower.
Hey, the greatest attackers sometimes put up a facade
that they might sneak their way.
I don't need to explain myself to you, I'm Fabian Seacaster.
You 100% need to explain yourself to me.
I am Vice Principal Golden Horde.
I'm sorry I got mad at you.
You can still have the flower if you want.
Don't kid, don't kid.
I'm in the background praying.
He has absolutely not earned any congeniality for you at all.
I hit him too, so I'm worried that.
All right, that's immediate detention for both of you.
First day after school.
Fine.
All right, you see he gives you each a little red slip
and says, good grief, is there any other nonsense
happening here?
Good, behave yourselves and I'll see you at detention
after school. I'm so sorry. Red, you go to sneak it,
give me a stealth check. Oh, I don't know if that's really a skill I have.
Okay, I got an at one.
Your pulse is instantly in some trouble.
You walk into the teacher's lounge, you are in there for literally,
what do you steal as you go in there?
I'm just going through the fridge seeing what kind of food there is.
You see that there is a little Tupperware container with a transparent steak in it?
You can partially see through or ethereal. You see it says, ghost steak, please do not
eat for a ghost professor. Yeah, I'm gonna eat that. I take the ghost steak and I just
start eating it. You have a very fucking hard time grabbing it.
Fuck.
You see the door opens and this vice principal guy walks in and goes, okay, immediate detention.
We are three for three and I'm about to ring the first bell.
The crazy thing is you're just playing into my hand.
Welcome to my game, you just did exactly what I wanted you to do.
I don't know you, right?
It is baffling. I know, I know.
That's why I was able to two step around you.
Describe your two step to me.
How have you bamboozled me in this moment?
Walk me through how you've bamboozled me.
All right, my plan all along was to get caught
so I would get kicked out and you are just scooting me along.
I put my combat boots up on the table.
What's the deal with that steak?
I can't pick it up.
Right, it's for ghosts.
That's ghost food.
Now, I'm gonna be very honest with you.
I don't think you fully know what detention means.
You're not suspended.
Do you recognize me?
See, Luxie says, no.
Because last year I was on the cheer squad.
I was one of the girls that they used to throw up
into the sky because I was so teeny, tiny and cute.
I shouldn't be having a conversation with you alone
in the teacher's class.
Get the fuck out of here.
Get out of here. Okay, go leave. All right, good.
Bye. What's your name again? I'm Vice Principal Gold.